[MUSIC PLAYING]
GRAY: I am pleased to
welcome to the platform
the honorable Alice K. Wolf,
mayor of the city of Cambridge,
and the honorable
Virgilio Barco, president
of the Republic of Colombia.
President Barco will
now give the address.
President Barco.
[APPLAUSE]
BARCO: President Gray,
members of the board,
distinguished guests,
class of 1990--
in a few short days,
each of you will be
entering a new stage in life--
new careers, new
opportunities, new challenges.
In a few short months, I
will be leaving the office
of President of Colombia.
I have been on a long
and fascinating journey
since that day in 1943
when, like all of you today,
I received my degree from MIT.
I remember that day well.
So many things raced
through my mind.
So much was happening
in the world.
So much was happening so fast.
Social, political,
and economic orders
were turned upside down by
events around the world.
Overnight, it seemed borders
were changing in Europe.
No one was sure what
tomorrow will bring.
All of this must sound strangely
familiar to each of you
with the rapid rate of change
in Europe and around the world.
All of it may be a bit
overwhelming as well.
I can understand the feeling.
In my senior year, in my
room at the graduate house,
I remember feeling a bit
overwhelmed myself for what
the future might bring.
Little did I know that
a few years later, I
will be deeply involved
in politics, elected
to the House of
Representatives only
to have Congress shut down
as violence against my party
broke out.
A year later, I returned
to Boston with my new wife
to obtain a graduate
degree at MIT.
Soon after, my first
child, Carolina,
was born here at
Massachusetts General Hospital
at the same time my
friend and adjunct
professor, Paul Samuelson,
and his wife had triplets.
I knew I had to return to
Colombia in a time of crisis.
But little did I know what
extraordinary events would
shape my life in public service.
I have learned that
our lives and careers
are shaped by outside forces
often beyond our control.
Throughout our lives, we are
faced with important choices.
In the end, I
realize how important
it is to establish a set
of values and beliefs
to guide these choices.
I also realize that a strong
foundation in the humanities,
economics, and
technology was the key,
for it's through these
basic disciplines
that we manage change.
They are truly at the
core of social progress.
Now these enormously
powerful tools
of change rest in your
hands, and the fate
of future generations
depends on your ability
to put to a good use all
that you have learned.
Your families, your
professors, and I
are all confident that each
of you can meet the challenge.
This pace of change under
rigors of academic life
have, at times, I am sure,
left you gasping for breath,
wondering if the world
of learning around you
will ever slow down.
Today would you kindly
stop and take a breath?
Look back on the years
you have spent at MIT.
Look beyond the long
hours and hard work.
What you have achieved
today is a true compliment
to all of you, and you should
stop and savor the moment.
Commit to memory the
time you have spent here
and what you have done.
In the future,
you will look back
on these years as a time
of great excitement,
of great challenges,
and of great ideas.
It was a time when many
of life's mundane details
could be set aside, so you could
focus on ideas, on learning,
on experiencing the
thrill of academic life.
You will look back at
these years as a time
when life was lived to
its fullest, when bonds
of friendship were built--
bonds that will last
your entire lives.
Never forget that what
you have learned here.
It will serve you well
for years to come.
Indeed, it has
served me very well.
In many ways, this is also
a proud day in my life.
Today I also find myself
poised at the edge
of a new time in my life.
This speech to the class
of 1990 at my alma mater
will be one of the last major
speeches of my presidency.
Soon I will depart
elected office
and seek new
challenges in my life.
Some have asked how I
manage the job of president
at such difficult times.
I tell them that it is nothing
compared to taking the oral PhD
examination at MIT.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
In many ways, my situation
is much like yours.
Together we enter a
new time in our lives,
a time with new opportunities
and new responsibilities.
We must enter this
new time bravely,
holding dearly to
the values that we
have been taught
to cherish at home,
at school, and here at MIT.
No doubt-- all of
you expect me to talk
about an issue that
has stirred the hearts
and minds and emotions of
millions around the world.
It is an issue I have
come to represent,
one which has even led to some
controversy in this campus.
I am sure you expected me
to use this time with you
to discuss the scourge
of illegal narcotics.
But that is not what I have
come here to speak about today.
I hope my views on this
issue are well known by now.
Every day you read
about our struggle
against narco-terrorism and
drug trafficking in Colombia.
This struggle will
continue when I
leave office, for good men
and women everywhere will not
tolerate misery and violence
bred by those who push
and those who consume
illegal drugs.
[APPLAUSE]
No.
Today I want to explore with you
a wider vision and the events
that will shape a new global
order in the 21st century.
For all days, a day which has
such personal [? importance ?]
to me and to each of you, this
is the day to look forward,
not to look back.
Like more of you
here, in Colombia,
we watched on television
the wall come down in Berlin
with rapt attention.
From people of power in
the Philippines to Václav
Havel's Velvet Revolution
to the no vote in Chile,
democracy is on the rise around
the globe as totalitarian
governments are tossed off by
people restless to experience
a world of freedom.
For all these devoted
to the cause of freedom,
we share in the
celebration of democracy.
[APPLAUSE]
Democracy is not a distant
notion at all in Colombia.
Indeed, our position in Latin
America is somewhat unique.
Our constitution is
nearly as old as yours,
and our democratic
institutions have long
been a model to our neighbors.
This is the true significance
of your current struggle,
for the greatest
threat to our democracy
is narco-terrorism and the
insatiable worldwide demand
for drug which fuels it.
In the past, we usually
saw extremist ideologies
as the most serious
threat to democracy.
But now drugs and organized
crime are even more dangerous--
not only to our democracy,
but to yours as well.
This is an auspicious moment
to reflect on our changing
world and a new global order.
Look at what has happened
since I graduated from MIT.
In 1943, a terrible war was
raging in Europe and in Asia,
taking lives and devastating
the countryside at every turn.
No one can ever forget
the tragedy of this war--
the 45 million killed; the Nazi
death camps; the destruction
of towns, cities--
of lives and hopes of
generations to come--
the use of atomic weapons
at Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
Seven years later,
when I returned to MIT
for postgraduate
studies, Europe was still
rebuilding the ravages of
this war, of the Cold War--
appeared to be a reality
that will never leave.
Soviets and Americans
stood poised,
ready to strike each other
at a moment's notice,
threatening the existence
of the human race.
Around the world,
democracy was in retreat,
and totalitarian
regimes flourished
on nearly every continent.
The result of totalitarian
regimes in Latin America
was the same as everywhere--
the crushing of the
will of the people,
the violation of
fundamental human rights,
the demise of democracy.
[INAUDIBLE] in this Cold
War, the developed world
chose to look the other way
as millions in Latin America
suffer under oppression.
US foreign policy
remained fixated
on East-West competition.
A North-South view
rarely came into focus.
And yet, in the last
decade, democratic change
has swept our continent.
10 years ago, most
countries of Latin America
suffered under the
weight of dictatorships.
Just look at the change.
Peru returned to democracy
in 1980, Bolivia in 1982,
Argentina in 1983,
Brazil in 1985--
Chile, Nicaragua, and Panama
in the last year alone.
Almost a whole continent
has moved from military rule
to legitimately elected leaders.
But still, as evidence of
North American [INAUDIBLE]
to the Cold War ideology,
these dramatic changes
so close to your
borders received
relatively little attention.
Now it's time to open
our eyes to a new world.
After years of superpower
conflict, each one of you--
what each one is vying for
gains in the high-stakes game
for global military advantage.
We are now able to see beyond
the East-West confrontation.
Today's global order no
longer rests on the foundation
of security concerns.
Military might is no longer what
determines a country's place
in the international system.
We are now able to look beyond
the myopia of the Cold War,
beyond our previously
clouded horizon,
to where a new world is
waiting; a world where
economic growth and
technological innovation
will be of critical importance,
not sheer military strength;
a world where entrepreneurs and
innovators will lead the way,
not the generals of yesterday.
Witness Japan, a country that
spends little on its military
but that has suddenly leaped
to the front ranks of world
powers.
It is a country that
gives more economic aid
to the third world
than any other nation,
including historically
generous United States.
The small military
establishment of Japan
presents no serious
threat to the vast armies
of the US or Soviet Union.
But through its
economic might, it
wields through global
influence today.
Which country, I ask, do others
most want to emulate today--
Japan or the Soviet Union?
The economic growth
through Asia and in Europe
has been extraordinary.
Now we must work to expand
the economic success
of these dynamic
regions to other areas.
This is particularly true for
the fragile new democracies
of the world.
For these countries to
solidify their political gains,
they will need economic success.
From Poland to Argentina
to the Philippines,
newly free people
expect economic growth
and improved living standards.
And in order to
maintain stability,
this expectation must be met.
It is your
responsibility and those
in other wealthy countries
to ensure the fostering
of global economic growth.
In this way, you can help
these fledgling democracies
as they struggle to
spread their wings.
This is especially
true in Latin America,
a region which,
historically, has received
far too little attention.
The best way to foster
North-South cooperation
will not be through
military means
but rather by
guaranteeing access
of Latin America's democracies
to economic prosperity
and change.
Just as history will
record the 1980s as an era
when democratic forces
swept the globe.
It will also be remembered
as a decade of resurgence
in free market economics.
This is a revolution of
enormous significance,
a recognition of
our global economy
and a confirmation that
open economies with access
to markets can lead
to social progress.
It seems that the
long-running match
between Karl Marx and Adam Smith
is finally coming to an end.
[APPLAUSE]
I applaud this development.
But at the risk of sounding
passé, let me issue a warning.
In our rush to embrace
free market forces,
let us not lose sight of the
fundamental role of government.
It embodies the free and
collective will of its people.
There is a role for
both market forces
and the state in
solving social problems.
Free market policies
should not be
used as an excuse for the
lack of political will
where it is a sure injustice or
fight in our drug trafficking
or providing basic
education and health care.
Free market economics
is not a magic wand
which, somehow, will relieve
us of the obligation to care
for our fellow human beings.
[APPLAUSE]
Nowhere is the role
of the state as
clear as with
another global issue,
which has been pushed
aside for too long--
the preservation
of our environment.
This is a struggle that must be
one of our highest priorities
in the decade of the '90s.
I firmly believe that the
industrialized countries have
an ecological debt to humanity.
[APPLAUSE]
In less than two centuries,
industrial development
has not only destroyed most of
the native forests of Europe
and North America, but also has
brought pollution, acid rain,
and destruction to
the ozone layer.
This is an ecological debt
to future generations, who
will have to live
with the consequences
of our thoughtless ways in which
the developed countries have
achieved their
standard of living.
The burden of sustaining a
viable planetary environment
now rests clearly on the
shoulders of the third world,
for we are the last
frontier of unspoiled lands.
The only way our countries
can meet this challenge
is by defeating rural poverty
and economic stagnation.
The best way for
the United States
and other
industrialized countries
to pay their ecological
debt to humanity
is to be the partners
in this cause.
My administration
has already set aside
more than 40 million acres of
rainforest as Indian reserves
in the Amazon region, an area
larger than the six New England
states together.
[APPLAUSE]
Let us pledge to seek some
development policies which
recognize the value of our
most precious resources.
Let us pledge to
retire this debt now
for future generations.
[APPLAUSE]
You are, indeed,
as fortunate as I
was to be embarking
on new careers
during a watershed period.
The record of human history
is marked by these moments
of fundamental change.
You will now inherit
a new global order
with new challenges and
extraordinary opportunities.
As you watched the joy of your
young German colleagues dancing
in the streets or the sorrow in
the faces of those brave young
students at Tiananmen
Square or the courage
of young Colombian soldiers
fighting for democracy
against narco-terrorists, it
may have been difficult for you
here on this beautiful
campus in Boston
to truly appreciate
such democratic fervor.
Here in America, where so much
is so often taken for granted,
the struggle for democracy
may, indeed, seem distant.
However, you are all
new graduates of one
of the world's most prestigious
academic institutions.
That honor brings with it
a special responsibility.
The new democracies
around the world
are fragile and need
your help to survive.
As you look to your
future, I ask one thing.
Do not let today's flowering
democracies wither on the vine.
[APPLAUSE]
Extend your arms to those
who have, for too long,
lived in oppression, in
fear, and in poverty.
Like all the newborns,
these infant democracies
around the world may, at
times, falter and stumble,
hesitantly trying
their first steps.
Yet they must prevail.
This is our first duty.
All of us, especially you
here in the United States,
now have an opportunity
to build in peace what
is often unavailable by force.
It is our collective
responsibility
to ensure that this opportunity
does not pass us by.
You have been well trained.
I have no doubt that you
have the intellectual power
to face any challenge.
I harbor the hopes
that you will also
have the heart to meet these
challenges with fairness
and compassion.
I know you will.
For this, after all,
is our shared heritage.
And you, my friends, are now the
guardians of our shared vision.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]